[Music]
hello and welcome to dear Hank and John
there was I first think of the dear john
and hank it's a comedy podcast where two
brothers answer your questions give me
two beasts advice and big you all the
week's news from both Mars and AFC
Wimbledon John yes what is the elephant
in the room I don't know how much longer
this bit is gonna last but all right
let's do it Hank three two one
[Laughter]
in the room of the overwhelming elephant
and really the elephant in every room an
American life right now and no doubt
listening in on our recording of this
podcast oh man I'm sorry I definitely
peaked on that one John I had my mic
sensitivity up a little too high so my
apologies to everybody's ears but I was
just very excited that we have the same
elephant finally yeah well so this was
the week when Donald Trump and Vladimir
Putin met in Helsinki Finland and well I
would say that I would say that things
went about as expected which is to say
that John Trump continues to have a jet
to me at least a genuinely baffling
relationship with the President of
Russia and we should say here that
Russia is a large and tremendously
diverse country of more than a hundred
million people and in American discourse
I think a lot of times there is this
kind of mono with the sizing of course
Russia yes thats anonymizes russia with
vladimir putin that is wrong and it's
the wrong way to talk about any country
but the American government's
relationship with the Russian government
seems very different from the leader of
the American government's relationship
with the leader of the Russian
government which is odd and like almost
without precedent as far as I can see in
recent American history yeah
yeah and I mean it's it's important to
recognize that Russia has done a lot of
things that that you know are contrary
to a general goal of stabilization of
geopolitics particularly violating
sovereign borders and and encouraging
the use of weapons that should you know
we've agreed as a global community not
to use those you know that those things
are pretty pretty significant reasons to
not be friends and I'm actually not
again what concerns me the most is that
we see that the government of the United
States cemar I have a very different
position even the executive branch of
the United States seems to have a very
different position than the president
which tells me that something is amiss
but we can't know quite what with we are
living amid history Hank as is always
the case and this story will only be
written by history but I suspect that we
will listen back to this recording of
this podcast at some point in the future
and be like hmm they didn't know
something that turned out to be
important as if you listen to old
episodes of dear Hank and John you no
doubt will think to yourself many times
every episode I mean it is our area of
expertise failing to know things that
turn out to be important oh goodness
if there was if there was a week in
which you could have a short poem for me
I wish I had one for you but I just I do
want I do want some kind of palate
cleanser so instead let me tell you a
story about my baby John please do every
morning that I don't get up before
Katherine or and will inevitably come
into the bedroom while I am still in bed
and and then Orin will point at my
nightstand and he will say daddy and I
will put on my glasses and then he will
accept the fact that I am there oh
that's how you become his father yeah
like before that he won't even look me
in the eyes that's very cute he's like
afraid he's like who is this all
Dadda that happens once a morning in bed
and only then yeah that's very cute my
kids also don't think that I look like
myself until I'm wearing my glasses kind
of tell you a cute Alice story okay yes
please Alice and I were out to dinner a
few nights ago and I told her that while
Taylor had left AFC Wimbledon no no and
Alice's response was pretty adorable she
said why would someone leave the best
soccer in the whole entire world
[Laughter]
just genuinely baffled like but they're
the best soccer at the whole entire
world and then henry god bless him was
like Alice there they're not this is a
story that your dad has been telling you
that is not not really locked in with
reality you're gonna have to learn a
thing or two about dad yessuh Sarah Lee
doesn't necessarily know like not
everything is totally 100% true all
right let's move on to questions from
our listeners this first question comes
from Mary who writes Dear John and Hank
so my mom and I were talking and we
started to wonder why is there no 25
dollar bill oh god Mary like we need to
introduce more currency to the United
or just more complexity to the system
let's just don't steal what the problems
we have I'll read the rest of the
question I feel like it would make more
sense to make dollar bills mimic our
coin values we should have a one dollar
bill if we're gonna mimic coin values we
should not have a one dollar bill
because we should not have a one cent
coin a five dollar bill again shouldn't
exist a ten dollar bill a 25 dollar bill
and so on just as we have pennies
nickels dimes and quarters why is there
a 20 dollar bill and not a 25 dollar
bill should we eradicate the twenty
dollar bill along with pennies and
replace it with the 25 dollar bill
pumpkins and penguins Mary Mary thank
you for acknowledging the importance of
eradicating pennies the greatest problem
our species currently faces and the one
that Congress seems least interested in
solving John
do you know why we have 25 cent coin
instead of a 20 cent coin I don't tell
me neither do i but I'm gonna say this
confidently and it will sound like it's
true back in the day you'd have oh you'd
have a 1 cent coin mm-hmm I mean a one
dollar coin or a one whatever unit coin
sure and the and then in order to like
divide that up you would physically
divide the coin mm-hmm and so it's much
easier to divide the coin into quarters
than it is to divide it into into fifths
which would be 20 cent coins and that is
my guess based on based on things that I
know about the past as to why we have 25
cent coins now that doesn't tell me why
don't have 25 dollar bills but maybe
because it doesn't make as much sense I
actually think that's a perfectly good
hypothesis but the larger point here is
that we do not need to introduce a new
kind of bill to the United States
currency system what we need to do
immediately is eliminate both pennies
and nickels which now cost the US Mint
tens of millions of dollars in losses
per year it is ludicrous the United
States lost 70 million dollars minting
pennies last year and what did we get
for that 70 million dollars
we got a currency that no one uses to
purchase goods or services it I cannot
believe that pennies are still happening
15 or 20 or 40 years after we should
have gotten rid of them it is a true
study in the inefficiency of the US
political system but I don't think we
need to introduce a 25 dollar bill
because it works fine to have 20s you
know what I think is interesting about
this question though John is that at
some point there was a decision made you
know like there what like some somebody
somewhere made this happen and and maybe
it was just sort of like like they had a
bunch of bills and this is the one that
people were using the most maybe it was
a collective decision I don't know how
it happened but no matter what there was
a point at which this like thing that
that affects our daily lives
like what's in our pockets everyday a
lot but at the same time if someone had
made a different decision it wouldn't
have had any impact on anything so I
think that's very interesting these big
things that like do have like they do
like effect this like surface level
examination of what the world is like
but if we'd gone with twenty five dollar
bills nothing would have changed yeah
that's very true the world would
essentially be the same place yeah but
it would be it would still like it but
if you lived in that world like suddenly
that would like everything changed I
have twenty five dollar bills it would
still be very weird and upsetting and
strange and awkward like there would
there would be that like deeply uncanny
Ness to the world if suddenly like your
twenty dollar bills all have five not
not that deeply uncanny like I think
things would be fine like if that's my
sliding doors movement and tomorrow I
wake up in a completely different
universe that's the exact same except
for 20 bills our 25 dollar bills like I
really don't think like the core stuff
in my life is gonna change that much no
but wouldn't it be like wouldn't it
wouldn't you know that something had
happened
unlike never be able to give that up
yeah I I would I would say Dussehra I
would be like listen in my reality
yesterday we had $20 bills and she would
be like I don't know what you're talking
about we've always had 25 dollar bills
and it would bother me for the rest of
my life yes although actually in my
particular case I think I would quickly
accept it because I do quickly accept
that kind of thing because I'm just like
I got enough mental health problems
without adding that to the pile and so I
just let it go
it's totally like I think that is
definitely the healthiest way to
approach it be like well I'm not gonna
get back to the $20 universe because I
don't know how I got to this right just
took time so let's just lets it be like
I was the thing that happened in my
brain maybe I should go get it maybe I
should go get an MRI or something but
other than that we're done we're done
worrying about this did I ever tell you
about when I became convinced that I'd
who is an aided no all right so one day
I'm walking over to my garden
and a black cat falls from out of the
sky and lands about five feet in front
of me and it looks at me in a panic and
then it runs away and I look up and
there is a tree up there but it's like
way high up there and I'm like well that
was weird and then I keep walking and I
see this deer with like huge antlers
which you never see in the city of
Indianapolis just standing about five
feet in front of me and I was like all
right I mean this is getting a little
weird fine
stuff happens maybe the deer scared the
cat out of the tree
whatever this is good I water the
flowers for like 45 minutes and then I
walk back and as I'm walking back I see
three people who appear to be in the
Tour de France like in full-on like
biker outfit going incredibly fast and
they turn into my driveway the driveway
of my home and then they disappear like
behind a wall and then I was like all
right we've we've got a problem like we
have a we have a level-one emergency
problem and I'm walking up to my house
and the whole time I'm just thinking one
of two things is about to happen either
I have to call Sarah and tell her that
we have a level one emergency problem or
they're gonna be three guys sitting
there taking a rest from their bike trip
and I turned the corner and it was the
latter one of them was like affiliated
in some way with the renovation that was
happening okay they were like oh yeah I
just wanted to show my buddies the work
that we've been doing on our outdoor
kitchen and they're like drink in there
like juice packs with the protein in it
everything and just sweating buckets and
I was like I was so relieved I was just
like you have great awesome and can you
guys just confirm for me real fast that
you are human if I poke one of you this
next question is important John it's
important that it comes from Megan who
asks dear Hank and John my name is Megan
I recently turned 18 and I'll be going
to college outside of my home state in
the fall I plan to register to vote but
I'm not sure how voting will work since
I'll be going to a school in a state
that it's not my state well I need to be
home on voting day to vote on issues
pertaining to my state will I be
confined to voting on things that are in
the ballot in my college state until I
graduate
thank you for your dubious advice
mangoes and monkeys Megan do you know
the answer this question job I know that
this is one of many ways in which the
fact that it is difficult for young
people to vote is essentially weaponized
by power structures to keep young people
from voting and as a young person I know
the lot of young people listen to this
podcast who may have recently become
adults or who are about to become
official adults do not let intentional
complexity added to the system to
disenfranchise you stop you from making
your voice heard because if you do that
you're giving them exactly what they
want the people who don't want you to
matter to the election process you are
giving them the exact thing that they
have sought so figure it out and vote I
agree with that a hundred percent and
there is some element of like you will
have to figure this out for your
particular situation but basically you
have to probably you have to choose
which place you would like to vote and
register to vote in that place there are
some places where college students have
to vote in in the place where they came
from not in the place where they are
currently living and so you would have
to register in your home state where you
came from and and yes this is
intentional complexity that has been
added to the system and then you will
have to absentee vote in that place and
so you probably should be setting that
up as quickly as you can because in some
places absentee deadlines are quite
early but you can literally Google how
to vote in and the name of the state
where you are from and figure that out
and you have to do that you have to do
that soon in fact go ahead and hit the
pause button
and just do it in everybody excellent
point John everybody if you're over 18
and you haven't registered to vote pause
right now just do it right now it only
takes like 10 or 15 minutes you'll be
you'll be done you'll have done it just
Google how to how to read it's like just
Google register to vote in the state
that you want to register to vote in
that also was the place where you live
Hank I completely agree we are moving on
to another question this one's from
Taylor who writes hello John and Hank
I've had this conversation a bunch of
times with a bunch of people and this is
it is there at least one person from
every country in New York City right now
I think yes but I've had many people
disagree I'm curious to hear what you
guys think best wishes Taylor from
Bozeman Montana oh hey Taylor in Bozeman
Montana
God Hank are basically neighbors you're
only a six hour drive away from each
other I am very interested in the answer
to this question I don't my guess my
guess would be that there are times when
there aren't I think that there are
probably times when there aren't I think
a lot of times there is a person from
every country in New York City but I
think unlike January 17th maybe not like
I've lived in New York and on January
17th and also in like the height of the
summer it's basically empty who's there
there's hardly any work city there's
hardly anyone work it was my it was my
favorite time to be a little bit
everybody takes their vacation it's the
one time of year when people leave the
island of Manhattan I I think look let's
think of it this way San Marino has a
population of what like twenty thousand
people I think it's unlikely that one
person from San Marino is in New York
all the time right yeah and it does sort
of come down to what you count as a
country too because there are that like
in the Vatican there's only like 800
residents so you dry out the Vatican
I wouldn't like you probably should only
count like UN recognized countries John
did you know that there's a country
called the Caribbean Netherlands I did
not yeah I did not um did you know did
that that sounds that sounds like the
best about like
is it the best of both of those places
cuz that sounds like a good place I
agree the idea of the Caribbean
Netherlands I mean you just named two
places I love so I'm definitely
interested I'm looking where they are
located and I can't help but notice that
the Caribbean other ones are a bit
closer to South America then I would
like in terms of proximity to my current
home I don't know what that means
like it looks like it would be a long
flight oh yeah I think it'd be a pretty
along the fight I was also a little
surprised to find that it is really not
in the Caribbean
yeah the Caribbean other ones look
lovely but I just don't think they can
compete with Indianapolis in July this
next question comes from Heather who
says oh no dear Hank and John I
accidentally ruined my close friends
shirt my friend Ryan I don't believe you
that'ss told me that it was alright but
he hasn't even worn that shirt yet I
looked online and in the store but I
couldn't find this shirt what do I do
hope is the thing with Heather yeah it's
pretty good Heather I'll give you four
four stars out of five on that one we
don't know what happened we don't know
what happened to the shirt like is it
truly ruined was this a thing where you
like over ironed it was a thing were you
in the dryer I I think it ruined you
think they're coming back
yeah I mean I think III could imagine a
number of circumstances I once threw a
just a piece of wet like like spaghetti
sauce spaghetti onto a friend of mine I
was wearing a white shirt and it was not
funny to her in the way that I thought
it would be and I said nope that's it
that's like a joke that was last funny
in second grade yeah well it took me a
while to grow up and this was high
school you know we're not sure where we
what we are when were high school
students were terrible at everything or
at least I was and and and what I what I
found was that uh was that we just
needed to move past it like there was no
making it better it just did needed to
be it it
because because of the intentionality of
it right there was there was never we
just needed to move past it I mean but
right well they just needed to move past
it you had no trouble moving past it as
is obvious from the way that you're
telling the story just yes the KC needed
to needed to forgive me and I needed to
give her the time to forgive me and let
her know how that I that I that I was
aware of my infraction
it sounds like probably Heather you did
not intentionally ruin this shirt so so
it may be that your friend is trying to
tell you that they understand that
sometimes when you step on someone's toe
that hurt but everybody comes out of it
without anyone being at fault and and
it's it sounds like maybe no one was at
fault and so you don't you don't need to
worry too much about it also I would
argue that a new shirt getting ruined is
much much better news than a beloved
shirt getting ruined right like anytime
I get a new shirt there's like a 60 to
70 percent chance I'm never going to
quite like it oh yeah absolutely so it
might have been that you were just doing
Ryan a favor by allowing him to part
with a shirt that he was gonna hate
anyway I mean there are so many of those
shirts in my closet or I'm just like ah
this one that yeah I need to iron it
yeah I know I do you sure I've got all
these shirts I don't look at them and
I'll be like what was the person who
purchased this thinking I usually feel
walk me through the steps at the store
that led to that moment right your
shirts by the way I Hank to be
completely honest with you sometimes
you'll wear a shirt in a vlogbrothers
video and I like people who watch our
videos are so nice and they never
comment on our clothing but sometimes
you wear a shirt in a vlog with this
video and I will have to restrain myself
from commenting can't notice anything
but the shirt I think I have great
shirts I don't know what you're talking
about
well I don't worry I will be giving you
an example I look forward to it I do I
do feel strongly that a shirt that will
need to be ironed it needs to have a
label on it
that's vyses should be a government
regulation there should be a separate
tag that says needs ironing because I I
just can't I can't have a shirt like
that like eventually I'll wash it like
it'll be three times later and all of
the collar will be like weirdly crimped
in the the button line will have a fold
in it that just you can't get it out and
I'll just be like well I'm never wearing
this shirt again that's just where it's
at that's where I'm at
let's go on to Goodwill so I have an
update okay I found this shirt that
annoys me and you've worn it like three
times in the last month of vlogbrothers
videos so you obviously like it it's
there it's it's a it's a blue shirt with
like dots on it but the dots are very
unevenly distributed in a seemingly
random pattern just to frustrate me it's
in the video Jon's best gift to me for
instance yeah and what is going on with
the dots on that shirt I like that shirt
I mean is it oh you got it at a thrift
store okay I thought that maybe it was
some kind of I don't know like Morse
code or something but you actually were
just like at a thrift store and you
looked at that shirt and you thought I
would like to wear that on my body yeah
and I have worn in a lot of videos
recently so I do need to make note of
that so I don't I because I do have a
lot of shirts I don't need to hit the
same ones all of the time I'm glad we
could have this talk because now you
know that I don't like that shirt thanks
John I really appreciate that you're
welcome I think that's important
feedback to get sometimes this next
question comes from Ryan
rosianna notes in parentheses a real one
in as much as anyone is real dear I am
having a philosophical dilemma with
absolutely no real-life applicability
there are many sci-fi shows such as Star
Trek that use some manner of teleporter
to quickly transport a person from one
location to another
with a minimum of fuss ostensibly this
technology will destroy the original
version of the person being teleported
encoded and reproduce an exact copy less
transcription airs on the other end this
is a cause of concern for me what
happens to a person's consciousness when
they are teleported if my entire being
is destroyed and then rebuilt would I
retain my consciousness or what I cease
to comprehend where my original body was
leaving my body and life in the hands of
some other me please help me in this
conundrum because if it ever comes up I
want to be sure that I can trust myself
philosophy and Earl Grey tea Ryan Ryan
it's not ever going to come up so that's
good news the best news is it is a it's
an it's a known thing that in these
fictional worlds like how does this
function are you killing a person and
creating them in the same instant and
that's kind of okay because the net
outcome was that the person there is
still a person where there was a person
even if they aren't technically the same
person right miss videos about this on
YouTube minutephysics in CGP grey both
made really good videos about this
because tell because teleportation of
course isn't real and isn't likely to
become real although we've made plenty
of incorrect predictions on this podcast
who knows it's mostly philosophical
exercise and a bit of a rhetorical
question rather than one with real life
consequences the one that has real-life
consequences for me Ryan
is if I am NOT choosing my thoughts and
I am NOT choosing large swathes of what
people say is me then what exactly about
me is mine and that has something to do
with teleportation but it also has
something to do with you know for
instance the fact that bacteria tell you
when to feel anxious which is weird and
discomfort if they just increase your
odds of feeling anxious I think more
than telling you oh you know they tell
your brain some people have bacteria in
their guts that tell their brains that
they should feel anxious now or
potentially even that they should
experience major depression here's
what's interesting to me about this
question is that it's clear that
in the universe of Star Trek they don't
think about this anymore despite the
fact that it's definitely happening
which makes me think man people will
ignore anything for convenience right
you will not believe the crap that we
will normalize in order to have a faster
travel yeah oh yeah like imagine me I
may cease to exist I may literally die
right now but it will seem to me as if I
got to the planet without having to get
in a frickin shuttlecraft yeah okay I'm
doing yeah yeah people plays an
incredibly high value on convenience and
on time saving which of course is
hilarious because almost all of us spend
almost all of our time doing and
thinking things that you know like
squirrels could do and think like if I
think about what I did this morning I
basically did the grown-up human version
of hiding a bunch of nuts in a tree ya
know that's like what I do all day as I
did I just hide just find more nuts to
hide I was like oh man I got to make
sure that I hide these nuts in a tree so
that nobody comes and finds them and
also through the magic of compound
interest maybe I will magically have
more nuts in a couple years yeah what
I'm saying Ryan is don't worry about
teleportation we're just a bunch of
talking squirrels which reminds me that
today's podcast is brought to you by a
bunch of talking squirrels a bunch of
talking squirrels they built a
civilization on this this beautiful
plaintive vows that's amazing what an
accomplishment today's also brought to
you by the 25 dollar bill the 25 dollar
bill coming to you as soon as we
eliminate the penny and also this
podcast is brought to you by
hallucinogenic bike teams just a few
bikers gone their way to the Tour de
France after you see a cat fall out of a
tree all
Psalm 2 at a big old deer with antlers
and lastly today's podcast is brought to
you by convenience convenience we will
give literally anything for it
and also John I wanted to tell you about
pod con do you know about pod Conor you
aware about can I say a word pod kind a
bunch of times now because I'm very
excited about pod con I am also really
excited about pod Conn pod con is a
conference that celebrates the world of
podcasting and there will be a there was
a wonderful pod con last year and in
wonderful news there is going to be
another pod Con this year Hank when is
pod con happening where is it happening
and where can I get tickets
well pod cam is happening in Seattle
Washington it's happening not this year
it's happening very early next year
January 19th and 20th
so because we skipped a year we can't
call it the second annual pod con which
is terrible just alright the second pod
con we are calling it pod con - it's ok
great - sorry I'm excited about pod con
- and here are some testimonials from
people that I received on Twitter this
was legit one of the best cons I've ever
attended to see my favorite podcasts
live and discover ones I had never heard
of was a perfect blend for my social
anxiety brain I would replace my legs
with mustard to have another pod con I
would become an astronaut and punched
the Sun for the light that is pod con
that's actually something that someone
wrote to me on Twitter Wow thank you
it's that's impressive
that's very that's that I really
appreciate how much you liked the event
I also had a very good time we have just
launched our crowdfunding campaign for
pod con you can find that if you go to
pod con com there will be a link to it
and we have many podcasts already
already confirmed creators from the
stoop the broadswords done a 9%
invisible oh no Ross and Carrie the
McElroy brothers the night Vale guys
hello from the magic tavern we'll be
there Catherine is coming we're gonna do
a live delete this and we're gonna do a
live dear Hank and John and we're gonna
have a lot of fun
it's a very it was such a weird fun cool
event and and I think Seattle is a great
place to have it I know that January in
Seattle is not the most exciting place
and time to be but the good news is that
that's how we
baked pod con work is by not having it
in peak season because the thing much
cheaper here it'll be really fun Hank
how much tickets cost there are a number
of different ways to attend we have
remote attendants where if you can't
come to the physical event you'll get
all of the things that happen to the
event delivered into the pod cast
application of your choice and you can
listen to the massive podcast but if you
want to be there physically the base
price is ninety five dollars during the
crowdfunding campaign and then the price
goes up thirteen percent after the
campaign ends so there are also a number
of things that you can only get during
the campaigns go on the pod can calm and
see what kind of fun we're gonna have
and whether you want to join us for this
really special great moment that uh that
I'm so glad that I get to share with a
bunch of people the last thing I'll say
about pod con is that it will be for me
the very first time that I have ever
debuted an episode of my podcast the
anthropocene reviewed live I'm nervous
about that but also really excited I'm
gonna write some anthropocene reviewed
essays specifically for pod con and then
record them there so it should be fun if
you like and the anthropocene reviewed
or any of the stuff that we do we would
love to meet you at pod Conn pod con-com
thanks thanks also we have a project for
awesome message from Sam from Southern
California who donated to the project
for awesome to get us to read this if
you're on the lookout for quality vlog
channels check out youtube.com slash
thins games with one N that's fi NSG a
mes fit as a charismatic young graphic
designer and videographer from Canada
who produces a variety of content
focusing on vlogs which are always fun
and uplifting from exciting travel vlogs
to activities around his Canadian home
town his content is superbly edited and
family-friendly that's youtube.com slash
Finn's games check it out today thank
you Sam and thank you fin check out
youtube.com slash Finn's games cool
let's go back to some questions John
this one comes from Katherine who asks
dear Hank and John I have a very large
garden and we have a lot of sugar snap
peas and I've been eating these almost
every day as they make a delicious snack
but I've noticed that there's always an
odd number of peas and the pie
why confused by legumes Catherine
Catherine you are confused by legumes on
a number of levels confused John have
you ever noticed that there is only
because I've definitely seen even in odd
numbers in my Peas but the the more
important thing here is that you don't
look at the peas right it should be a
Schrodinger's pee situation Catherine
you shouldn't know how many peas are in
your sugar snap peas because you just
eat it all at once with the pod you
don't look carefully out it you just get
that crunchy deliciousness so I think
you're stressing out about something
that you shouldn't even be noticing
which come to think of it as the story
of 95% of my life I sometimes I think
that people like I I think people are
missing out on some of the greatness of
a sugar snap pea by only eating the peas
the wonderful part of the sugar snap pea
is how good the pod is you cannot go to
break off the ends if you really want to
but in general let's throw that whole
thing in your mouth you don't even need
any ranch dressing for that to be a
delicious snack I love it I will say
garden fresh sugar snap peas like from
the moment they are taken from the plant
and placed in my mouth if one of the
best foods I've ever had I made that
video about not sugar snap peas but like
regular English green peas I made that
video about how to cook eight peas and a
bunch of people are like no no no you
should just eat them directly off the
vine which is such good advice the
remaining like 12 to 14 peas that I got
from my lab I ate directly like while I
was still in the garden the moment that
I the moment that I harvested them and
it was just so good I by the way I have
been having the best time gardening as I
hope you noticed Hank in my video about
how to eat 213 Tomatoes i-i've just it
is just a blast it is a good it's a
really good activity where our first
tomato just came off the plant and or
and ate it all by himself so you get to
try it well that's impressive my
children sadly do not like tomatoes or
at least they claim not to I think that
eventually they'll come around this next
question comes from Krista who asks dear
John and Hank what does space smell
um well if you were to just go out into
space and take off your space helmet and
take a deep breath all the air would be
sucked from your lungs and you would
suffocate but if you if you took space
and you compress like out a lot of it
and a compressed it down real real tight
until it was about the like a breathable
imp like a breathable density of atoms
and molecules then apparently according
to an article that I read a space would
smell like uh like burning stuff like
NASCAR race and barbecue because those
molecules get thrown off of uh get
thrown off of stars when they explode or
those yeah that they're they're
basically hydrocarbons so you would uh
that's mostly what you would smell
because you wouldn't smell the hydrogen
because hydrogen doesn't have a smell
but you would smell the smell the
hydrocarbons which would smell like
burning stuff I find it fascinating that
you think that NASCAR races and
barbecues smell the same not both of
those things not not like that's what it
would it's both of those things combined
ah ok so it's like it would smell like
having a barbecue at a NASCAR race yeah
correct so where does the smell of all
of the like human body odour come from
in space
wait what Oh didn't get that joke at
first okay John let us attempt to give
some actual advice to an actual person
this one is from alyssum who asks dear
Hank and John my dad owns and runs a
small business and he found himself
without an office manager a few months
ago but wasn't in a place where he had
the time to hire and search for and
train a new office manager so I offered
to fill in until the company gets
through the summer crunch and he has
time again but working there I have
found out that he is a micromanager and
it's very irritating and frustrating
what do i do what do i do what do you
what do you do what it's your dad but
also this is not not great when it's
easier boss - I wonder if
alyssum dad is always a micromanager or
just a micromanager when managing a kid
because I micromanage my children's
lives in a way that I would never ever
manage people I work with
you know like absolutely I would for
instance people I work with I would
never say like I'm not sure you should
be friends with that person yeah yeah
and also like like you know I don't know
how many jobs you've had at this time
and I don't know how how old you are but
but maybe this is one of the first jobs
you've had and and maybe your dad is
trying to impart some some skills upon
you and that that feels like like he's
not doing in a skillful way and so it
feels like it's being perceived as like
do it this way do that this way to then
like looking over your shoulder all the
time when maybe he's trying to help you
out another example is that when one of
my employees stops by to tell me that
they're getting married
like I say a blanket congratulations no
nothing else you don't like you know
like check up on him you know check up
on the on who they're who they're
looking at where as getting it analyst
recently told me that she's getting
married to avi it was a nice kid don't
get me wrong but also five I said I
don't think that's appropriate and I
said you know you don't know who you're
gonna love in a long time and Alex was
like well you didn't know that you were
gonna love mommy in a long time when you
got married
oh gosh Alice you're not marrying auggie
it's that's
so that's how that conversation went
down precisely he's a nice boy but
you're five and if I said that to an
employee it would be extremely
inappropriate yes and also inaccurate
hopefully I think of a somewhat you got
it you got you got a dis grin and bear
this one hopefully you have a productive
relationship with your dad outside of
the outside of the business but but
unless unless you can can like sort of
leave and and have a little bit bit of
expertise that you're bringing it's
gonna be hard for your dad to be able to
take this this advice from you as as a
person who's running a business unless
he's like super super open to criticism
I don't know your dad yeah if your dad's
open to criticism I would say that you
could go and be like listen dad I
actually got this I think I understand
this I think I'm good on this part I
have yeah I'll have other questions on
other stuff but I think I'm good with
this yeah and he may listen to that he
may he may be able to hear you on that
if you're working in a big office and
everybody feels like your dad is a
micromanager and it's a problem for the
company then I would probably try to
find some way to talk to your dad about
that to be like I think you know people
actually know what they're doing and I
don't know it's hard though yeah this is
a tough one I think the main thing you
want to do here alyssum is a place the
father-child relationship before the
employee boss relationship because
that's gonna be the one that lasts for
more than the summer yeah also I just
think that's good advice in general Hank
and I always try to do that to remember
that our relationship with each other as
brothers is more important than any of
our business relationships with each
other and so we've got to prioritize
that that said I do report to Hank which
continues to be both hilarious and
inspiring because Hank is an incredibly
good boss like he provides great
feedback and makes you feel special
it's it's amazing I can't recommend Hank
as a boss enough and which is
interesting because I am
terrible boss so yeah I mean you you you
are you are just you know you've got a
lot to it you got a lot to think about
John you got a lot to focus on that's
that's the nicest way of putting it yes
we have a response an important email
response Hank that came in from Trent
Trent wrote in to say Dear John and Hank
last night at a bar in Madison Wisconsin
I was looking at the menu and we
surprised to see Zima was an option
wondering of course for those of you who
aren't aware Zima was a popular quasi
beer alternative in the early 1990s that
was responsible for I would say 80 to
90% of our early experiences without
thanking me wondering of course why Hank
so fondly remembered this beverage from
the decade I was born in I ordered it
I'll just tell you now Trent he
remembered it fondly because he was
drunk
the bartender replied you really want to
Zima and after I assured him that I had
meant to order it he half ran to the
other bartender and jumped up pushing
down the other bartender's shoulders as
someone does when excited he spoke quite
loudly when he said I just sold a Zima
upon returning with my beverage he
explained that they were doing a limited
run of Zima this year and that they had
never sold one when I returned to the
group there were many people asking me
what I was drinking and if they could
try a sip I actually quite enjoyed it
well clear well pretty sweet it was less
so than many other wine coolers so that
is how thanks to your podcast I became
the cool hipster ordering the drink that
no one had heard of thank you for that
experience Trent that's pretty great
yeah that is kind of what I like about
you know how I have had Zima since they
released it and I'm like yeah this is a
lot less sugary than like a Mike's Hard
Lemonade and that's kind of nice at the
same time but I would say that Zima is
responsible for a lot of bad mornings
and nights not just in my own life but
in general so always drink responsibly
yeah please drink responsibly on the
subject of alcohol consumption Hank I
recently took you know they're making a
Hulu series of
my novel Looking for Alaska my first
book is gonna be hulu series multi-part
I can't remember how many parts but like
one of those one season things yep and I
recently took Josh Schwartz and
Stephanie Savage who are heading up that
project and have been working on this
for literally thirteen years I recently
took them to my old high school and
showed them around some of the places
that I used in the book the book is
fictional but I based the physical place
pretty closely on the place where I went
to high school so I showed them all
these places took them to the Waffle
House tried to give them a good day you
know in Pelham Alabama and then at the
end they were like hey dude does that
place where you bought alcohol really
exist and I was like yeah so I took them
to the place where I bought alcohol as a
teenager don't do this obviously don't
buy alcohol underage this was a
different era the 1990s when laws were
different it was totally legal anyway I
took them there I purchased Strawberry
Hill
and we like drank a little Strawberry
Hill in the woods at Indian Springs
while just having a talk
I felt closer in that moment to high
school than I have felt in I don't know
15 18 20 years and I also have to say
that even though they were like oh this
is terrible I was drinking it and I was
thinking like you know for a $2 and
forty nine cent bottle of wine this is
not half bad Boone's Farm nothing wrong
with Boone's Farm
I don't why did I get a brand deal from
Boone's Farm for putting it's so front
and center in my first novel for
teenagers geez but seriously though dude
drink responsibly if you drink and also
if you don't drink great high fives all
right John do we have news from Mars and
AFC Wimbledon for people so much news
from AFC Wimbledon we are drowning in
AFC Wimbledon news it's been one of the
most eventful offseason weeks I can
remember in AFC Wimbledon's history AFC
Wimbledon have now signed seven
count'em seven new players it's
basically it's a whole new team you've
got you got players you got people
people welcome we've got players we've
got 22 year-old Terrell Thomas a
defender who has just signed from Wigan
we actually paid money for him ah which
is not usually pay money you just like
give them the salary or what right we
usually do not pay a transfer fee but we
did pay a transfer fee for this transfer
which means that you know it's a pretty
big deal
George long are brilliant goalkeeper
from last season did officially sign for
Hull City who are in the championship
and I think he's gonna have a great time
if it there I don't think that I've
talked about the fact that we signed
Anthony Wordsworth Anthony Wordsworth of
course the a relative one presumes of
England's fifth greatest lyric poet
Anthony Wordsworth signed from hold on
did it but but but but Anthony
Wordsworth signed from a fellow League
One side Southend United a very exciting
guy I mean I like the look of him I like
the way he plays so we've got Mitchie
pins
we've got Anthony Wordsworth we've got
this new guy Terrell Thomas I I just
feel like the squad is really coming
together and while I was super worried a
month ago I find myself being dare I say
it cautiously optimistic Wimbledon
season starts August 4th not too long
from now so I don't know how many more
signings we're gonna get maybe one I've
been hearing some rumors that there
might be one more coming in but we'll
have to see well that's I mean you don't
know how this team's gonna play until
it's a team right I mean is there a lot
of a lot of concern about the fact that
like these people are gonna know each
other that well as players or as people
not a ton did I tell you by the way that
we also signed a midfielder name's Scott
Wagstaff I mean the names right the
names are talking about wags I'm gonna
call him wags
Scotty wagging wags we got Mitchie pins
Scotty wags it's just it's gold
I don't even hurt it that's
I need to tell you okay we've got new
players I'm full of hope I actually just
talked to Eric Samuelson who is the
director of AFC Wimbledon about the new
stadium as well so the the greyhound
stadium is being demolished in fact if
you go to AFC Wimbledon's website you
can kind of watch pictures updated
almost every day of the demolition
project and then once it is ready to
build upon the stadium will start being
built that is gonna be expensive and
that's a big deal it is a big moment in
AFC Wimbledon's history for sure but
that that is it that will be the I mean
it for many people associated with the
club this will be the most important
thing that's ever happened to the club
to be back in Wimbledon
back at their historic home but in a
beautiful new stadium it'll just be a
new chapter in this club's already
incredible history so I'm really excited
all right well the news from Mars is
it's kind of news from Earth this this
weekend because it's about looking at
Mars from Earth so there is a time that
happens at regular intervals though it's
a weird interval when when earth goes
around its orbit Mars goes around its
orbit and then occasionally they line up
so they're on the same side of the Sun
at the same time and that's when Earth
Earth and Mars are really close together
and when it when Mars is directly
opposite from Earth that is also like
there's a line that you can draw from
the Sun to earth to Mars that's also
when Mars is basically full so this is a
this is a kind of a weird thing but as
planets go around the Sun from Earth
they wax and wane just like the moon
does for us except that the function is
different because that those planets
aren't going around us they're going
around the moon all right they're going
around the Sun so there are two things
that affect Mars as brightness in the
sky there's how close it is to us and
there is how much of the surface of the
Sun is being lit from our perspective so
when when it is in that position which
it will be at the
end of July so July 27th is when it will
be you know 100% full that is when it is
brightest in the sky so you'll be able
to look into the southeastern sky and
see you're really bright Mars for the
next month or so starting you know if
you go and and listen to this listen to
the podcast you can go look at it now
and I think that this is sort of like an
Northern Hemisphere thing though I'm not
entirely sure I only know it from I can
only tell you what I what like we see
here because I don't I'm sorry I don't
know how the planet works there's a lot
of other places and the sky is different
in them but but Mars is very bright in
the night sky right now so if you want
to go check out a real bright Mars or
even go and get a telescope and and take
a take a look at it that this is a one
of the best times to see it this is as
close as it's been as bright as it's
been since 2003 Wow so this is not quite
a once-in-a-lifetime opportunity but
certainly a once in a decade opportunity
yeah though if you looked in 2003 that
was once-in-a-lifetime that was as
bright as it was for the last like sixty
thousand years Wow well I feel like I
missed that completely yeah so that's a
bummer
it's funny I'll get you know a vague
notion of what it might have been like
by looking at from Indianapolis you said
the southeastern sky I think so yeah
alright cool I'll make it I'll make a
point of looking at it and I will report
back at our next pod okay thank you I
hope that you enjoy Mars John I've
really been enjoying the night sky
lately and you have something to do with
that Hank you have greatly improved my
appreciation for space since we started
making this podcast so thank you for
that and thanks to everybody for
listening we're gonna go over now to
make our hit podcast this week in Ryan's
available at our patreon patreon comm
slash dear Hank and John where you can
also get lots of free stuff without
signing up because we put all the
updates there this podcast is produced
by rosianna halse rojas and sheridan
Gibson it's edited by Nicholas Jenkins
the music that you're listening to right
now and at the beginning of the podcast
is from the brilliant gunnarolla our
head of community and community
patience is viktoria Bongiorno you can
email us at Hank and John all one-word
at gmail.com we love to answer your
questions and read the emails for
questions that we can't answer thank you
again for listening and as they say in
our hometown don't forget to be awesome
[Music]